the western or northwestern coast of
South America has been an interesting
place for ancient civilizations we
believed it to be one of the places that
agriculture developed independently and
as we'll see in this video and we've
talked about in other videos it's a
place where we have many significant
cultures and civilizations and empires
developing now what's interesting about
it is it is not your classic River
Valley Civilization like we have in
Mesopotamia or in ancient Egypt or along
the Yellow River in China or the Indus
River in India and Pakistan
instead this area is really defined by
the Humboldt Current the Humboldt
Current is a current that comes up from
the south and off the coast of what is
modern-day Peru for the most part it
brings all these nutrients from the
bottom of the ocean and what it does is
it makes it a very powerful fishery so
there's a lot of fish in the ocean in
this part of the world and it also has
interesting effects on the climate on
land so in this region you can see even
on this map there's this thin strip of
desert and then you get into the Andes
Mountains and on the other side of the
Andes Mountains you start to have the
tropical rainforest so if you go to Peru
especially on the western part of Peru
the ocean will look like this this is
actually a picture I took from a recent
family trip to Peru then as you get
right onto the coast it will be pretty
arid desert and then when you get up
into the mountains they're fairly high
altitude you'll have these mountain
valleys that are some of them are at
7,000 8,000 9,000 feet this is actually
another picture that I took from my
recent family vacation in Peru a few
months ago and what's interesting about
the ancient civilizations there is some
of them might have settled on the coast
to take advantage of the fishing that
was available there were some rivers or
there continue to be some rivers that go
from the mountains through the through
the desert so some early agriculture
developed around that but there's also
civilizations that developed around
these high-altitude valleys and what's
really interesting about these
civilizations is because of the terrain
they weren't as
unified as things that we might see in
Mesoamerica so one of the first
civilizations in all of the Americas
that we have archaeological evidence of
is the corral or Norte Chico
civilization and one thing to keep in
mind as I give the names of these
civilizations this is not what they call
themselves the civilizations tend to be
named after the most significant
archaeological locations that people
have found and now as we get into the
first millennium BCE we have what's
called the cha bean civilization once
again it wasn't there named this was
about 3,000 years ago and to be clear
this is when we just start to see that
civilization getting quite advanced
there's evidence that people had been
settled in this area around modern-day
Peru and Bolivia and northern Chile and
Ecuador for potentially thousands of
years before that but just to get a
sense of the chubbing civilization
here are some archaeological artifacts
discovered and they were discovered at
shebeen de huantar just thusly the name
shebeen civilization sometimes called
cha bean culture and what's interesting
is we have these artifacts it looks like
it was a religious cultural center some
people refer to as a religious cult that
really took off in this area but we
don't believe that it was a formal
Empire we don't know for certain because
we don't have written records so we're
just trying to figure out what we can
from the archaeological evidence now
near the time that the chubbie in
culture started to decline and what's
interesting we believe that a lot of
these cultures declined either from
warfare between themselves or some type
of climate change whether it was the El
Nino or some type of drought or famine
and maybe that could actually cause a
lot of the conflict within a society as
well but those are some of the leading
theories as to why the chopping culture
ended around 200 BCE now around that
time we start to see the emergence of
several other cultures you have the
famous Nazca culture emerge right over
here in southwest Peru and their most
famous perhaps for
the Nazca lines is huge I guess you say
drawings or our patterns that are made
in the land some of them are 300 meters
a third of a kilometer and you really
can't even appreciate what they
represent unless you're looking at it
from a significant altitude some people
have theorized that this is some type of
message they're trying to send to the
sky gods some people have even thought
hey maybe this has something to do with
trying to communicate with aliens this
is famously called the spaceman who
knows it's interesting to theorize about
that Nazca civilization which started to
emerge around 200 BC and once again we
don't have written records so we can
just look at their art there are their
architecture these patterns that they
created now a little bit later we start
to see the emergence of the Moche
civilization or the Moche culture in
this area in light blue right over here
sometimes called mo-chica and this is
one of the significant structures they
build huaca del Sol known as the temple
of the Sun and it's been damaged a lot
often times by people who are trying to
looted or excavated in irresponsible
ways but it was the largest structure we
have found from pre-columbian America
you say pre-columbian America were
saying before Christopher Columbus got
to America the Moche are really
interesting we even though they didn't
have writing we can learn a lot from
their art and this is some examples of
it and frankly this is some of the less
graphic examples of it now as we get
into the first millennium especially the
middle part of the first millennium we
start to see some other significant
cultures and civilizations emerge so for
example around 500 CE II so roughly 1500
years ago you see the wiry civilization
emerge and that's here in red and
there's some debates and you'll see
these debates a lot as we study ancient
history was it an empire or was it just
a culture that had a lot of influence
some of the arguments for empire it
seemed like there was there was wealth
it seemed like they were able to build
large infrastructure works there was
consistency across different settlements
now there's also the Tiwanaku and we
believe it was truly an empire but we
could say the Tiahuanaco civilization
right over here in yellow
really centered at off the coast of Lake
Titicaca which is right in that area
right over here but the big takeaway
here is this is just a sample of some of
the civilizations that you've had in
this part of the world now what's really
interesting is as I mentioned a lot of
them weren't able to form formal empires
people think because of the the valley
the mountains the terrain that we're
keeping people from maybe trading or
being able to control each other a
little bit more strongly but eventually
we do have the emergence of fairly
strong empires as we see in the Incas
which emerges in the fifteenth century
around 1438 and then the Inca Empire
ends with the European colonization of
the Americas and we also believe the
tihuanaco were significant Empire
despite some of the geographical hurdles